[موسيقى]
هذا نوع من السوشي كبير ، وإذا كنت
جائعًا بما يكفي لتناول هذا ، فهناك رجل
يجب أن تقابل شيطانًا شابًا آخر
راموس ، جمال الوحيد الذي يعرف أنها
اختبرت ، وهو يصنع أصغر
سوشي أيضًا
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في مدينة أنجيو في  اليابان موطن لمؤسسة
صغيرة بها أطباق ليست صغيرة جدًا ، كان
البطل مو يصنع السوشي
هنا لمدة 44 عامًا
[موسيقى]
أوه ، نعم ، أنت تعلم ، لا أعرف
أنها بصراحة أفعل شيئًا ما في
يوم من الأيام تحدى أحد العملاء في حالة سكر البطل مو
ل  صنع أكبر لفة سوشي
حتى يتمكن من إخراج الأعشاب البحرية
وتسليم من يعرف أنك كذلك ، لقد
فعلت أطباق Elemental Hero mu التي تصنع العديد من
أطباق السوشي العملاقة سيئة السمعة
[موسيقى]
اعتقدت أنه لا توجد معلمات جيدة ، حسنًا ، ساندي
الصيحة دوم ، السوشي الكبير الغامر يعني
أموالًا كبيرة  تكلفة الرومان السخيّة تكلف 146
دولارًا أمريكيًا تبدو هيلا د.  ماكنمارا ذلك
الرجل يحجز لك هذا ، يجب أن يحصل على صفقة جديدة
أو جونانا ،
يجب أن أبقى حقًا عليك أن تحرك البرج أنت
تعرف لماذا لم يكن لديك خطأ نيك يا
إلهي وماذا عن ثعبان البحر المفاجئ
أن رجل زومبي مثلك حق
آسف يا رجل غير آمن ، لذا أنت تعرف في الماضي
الكوميدي ميزونو سان أنت تفعل لا ، لكن إذا كانت
ثعبان السمك تبدو كثيرًا هنا وهناك
أيضًا خطة يمكن أن يذهل آكلو الفأس ،
فأنت نعم
ويحتاج المحليون إلى نظرة IV فهي قطة  a
la spada ، إنها خصم
مكروه تمامًا لرؤيتي
بطلًا يحرك السوشي المصغر الخاص به في علبة أعواد الثقاب ،
لقد رأيتني أذهب ، لذا انظر ليس فقط إلينا
إذا ذهبت إلي ، أليس كذلك في بعض الأحيان
يقومون بإعداد ما لم أكن أبدًا
رائع ، أنت
سلطتهم الشجاعة ، فقط
شهر واحد آخر ، عيون جيدة لكوكوي هي ليست
هناك تحمّل أنها تأتي إلى عمتها التي
تأتي على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]